zu uns die bundespressekonferenz ist
eine regierungsunabhängige organisation
ein verein von journalistinnen und
journalisten die in der bundeshauptstadt
über bundespolitik berichten und diese
pressekonferenzen hier organisieren
veranstalten und leiten wir freuen uns
heute sehr dass wir gäste haben nach
einer kabinettssitzung die ein wenig
länger gedauert hat deswegen sind
fliegen nicht ganz pünktlich mit dem
start ich begrüße neben mir
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz und
daneben bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer und es geht um den
kabinettsbeschluss zu den hilfen nach
dem hochwasser in rheinland pfalz und
nordrhein westfalen
herr scholz und herr seehofer werden
jeweils beginn ein statement halten
bevor wir zu ihren fragen kommen herr
scholz beginnt meine damen und herren
die katastrophe mit dem hochwasser
verbunden das ist unverändert da sie hat
große zerstörungen angerichtet viele
menschenleben gekostet viele sind
verletzt und unglaublich viele sind
immer noch vermisst das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen während wir jetzt darüber
reden was zu tun ist
unterstützungsleistung geht es ja immer
noch darum zu retten zu helfen und das
zu tun was notwendig ist
gleichzeitig ist es wichtig dass wir den
bürgerinnen und bürgern vor ort wenn man
das ausmaß der zerstörung gibt eine
klare schnelle und zügige botschaft
gehen ich habe mit vielen betroffenen
gesprochen viele andere das auch gemacht
und das will ich hier an dieser stelle
noch einmal sagen all die dramatischen
bilder die auch die medien uns als
bürgerinnen und bürgern zur verfügung
stellen die uns möglich machen einen
einblick zu gewinnen sind immer noch
ganz anders als das was man erfährt wenn
man vor ort ist wenn man mit den
betroffenen spricht wenn man sieht
welche dramatischen konsequenzen das für
das lebenswerk was alles zerstört worden
ist und deshalb ist es auch notwendig
dass es hier schnell eine botschaft gibt
dass es eine zukunft gibt dass wir uns
gemeinsam darum kümmern dass das eine
angelegenheit ist für uns als ganzes
land das wir helfen wir haben alle
notwendigen entscheidungen jetzt auf den
weg gebracht mit dem was wir heute im
kabinett beraten haben
das allererste dazu wird auch der
bundesinnenminister noch mehr sagen
können
wir werden natürlich alles das was wir
an hilfsleistungen zur verfügung
gestellt haben und noch zur verfügung
stellen gebührenfrei den gemeinden den
gegen die hilfe brauchen zur verfügung
stellen das ist aber die kleinste sache
die wichtigste schnelle botschaft ist
wir werden wie bei der flutkatastrophe
vor einigen jahren eine soforthilfe
mobilisieren für die haben wir jetzt
einen ungefähren bedarf von 400
millionen also für den bund etwa 200
millionen veranschlagt aber ich sage
ausdrücklich dass es die summe von der
wir jetzt ausgehen und wir haben uns an
dem orientiert was wir nach der letzten
flut katastrophe gebraucht haben nämlich
knapp 400 millionen euro
aber wenn es so ist dass mehr gebraucht
wird dann ist es so dass wir auch mehr
geld zur verfügung stellen werden die
länder und natürlich auch wir als und
mit unseren möglichkeiten wir werden das
tun was erforderlich ist um jeden so
schnell wie möglich zu helfen
und deshalb ist auch eine ganz klare
verabredung die wir als bundesregierung
getroffen haben die wir aber auch mit
den ländern besprochen haben
es wird von den ländern diese hilfe
organisiert die wird schnell zügig und
unbürokratisch zur verfügung gestellt
wir werden keine eigene bundes
infrastruktur mit genehmigungsprozess
mit allen möglichen daneben stellen
sondern wir stellen das geld zur
verfügung damit es schnell und zügig so
schnell wie möglich bei denen ankommt
die jetzt hilfe brauchen
das große langfristige projekt das vor
und steht ist die aufbauhilfe der aufbau
auch da können wir ja ermessen was die
letzte katastrophe für mittel notwendig
gemacht haben das sind um die sechs
milliarden bis jetzt es werden auch noch
mehr werden so lange zieht sich das hin
und wir werden deshalb auch jetzt bereit
sein das notwendige zu mobilisieren und
als bunt unseren beitrag nämlich
die hälfte davon zur verfügung stellen
und das geht auch sofort dass wir damit
jetzt anfangen es gibt also nichts womit
man zögern muss die zusage die wir jetzt
geben wollen ist dass diese aufbauhilfe
gleich beginnen kann und dass wir sie
zusammen mit den ländern auf den weg
bringen damit dort all das notwendige
getan werden kann um infrastrukturen um
kaputte häuser wieder herzustellen um
kaputte schulen krankenhäuser alles
mögliche was dort zerstört worden ist
wieder in ordnung zu bringen
das wird viel viel kraft und arbeit er
kosten aber es ist notwendig und bei
dieser gelegenheit ist es vielleicht
auch wichtig zu sagen dass wir das
natürlich selbstverständlich für unsere
eigenen infrastrukturen tun werden alles
das was und ist straßen eisenbahn und
andere infrastrukturen werden wir auf
kosten des bundes mit den mitteln des
bundes mit den möglichkeiten des bundes
wieder herstellen so haben wir das das
letzte mal zugesagt so wird es diesmal
auch sein
wir werden jetzt auch profitieren von
dem planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz in der
letzten jahre
denn wir werden für den wiederaufbau
nicht jedes mal neues planrecht brauchen
sondern wir wollen dass ohne neue plan
rechtliche regelungen machen wenn eine
brücke wieder hergestellt werden muss
wenn ein haus wieder neu gebaut werden
muss wenn eine schule wieder neu gebaut
werden muss muss man nicht ein neues
planfeststellungsverfahren auf den weg
bringen sondern kann das was da war
einmal wieder herstellen
natürlich auch optimiert das gehört dazu
da wollen wir alle freiheit dafür
schaffen wir werden die möglichkeiten
nutzen die der eu solidaritätsfonds
vorsieht und wir werden auf alle fälle
auch sicherstellen dass wir jetzt eine
debatte beginnen über die frage wie
können wir uns auf solche katastrophen
für die zukunft vorbereiten
da geht es auch um finanzielle fragen
das muss besprochen werden wir sind
bereit mit der länder gesamtheit darüber
zu reden wie absicherung gewährleistet
werden kann
damit nicht alles jedes mal dann ad hoc
gemacht werden muss sondern wir dazu
eine vereinbarung haben die dann immer
aktiviert werden
denn das will ich ganz klar sagen wir
müssen angesichts der veränderung damit
rechnen dass solche ereignisse uns
häufiger erreichen und wir müssen
deshalb auch dafür vorsorge treffen dass
das so ist es darf keine
individualisierung von risiken geben die
die ganze menschheit mit verursacht hat
durch den klimawandel das wäre
unsolidarisch das wäre auch nicht in
ordnung und deshalb wollen wir das
gespräch darüber mit den ländern
aufnehmen und sind bereit unseren teil
zu tun
damit alles gut und unbürokratisch läuft
werden wir einen ausschuss etablieren
dem das innenministerium das
finanzministerium auf bundesseite leiten
wo wir mit den ländern das erforderliche
besprechen
zusammenfassend es wird jetzt sofort
hilfe geben in der notwendigen
größenordnung für alle die das haben
unbürokratisch durch die länder wo die
zerstörung angerichtet worden sind
stattfinden
es wird jetzt begonnen werden können mit
dem aufbau
das wird milliarden schweren das wird
auch mehrere jahre in anspruch nehmen
aber wir sind bereit das gemeinsam mit
den ländern zu stemmen und auch
voranzubringen alle können sich jetzt
darauf verlassen dass es der wille den
wir dazu haben
und natürlich werden wir für die zukunft
vorsorge treffen müssen indem wir uns
auf solche stark mit der ereignisse
vorbereiten und in dem wir gleichzeitig
sehr sehr klar machen der
menschengemachte klimawandel muss
aufgehalten werden und da deutschland
eine große verantwortung das sind zwar
auch global stattfindende ereignisse
weil das klima global ist aber wenn wir
es schaffen in kurzer zeit ein
industrieland zu sein dass co2 neutral
wirtschaftet entwickeln wir die
technologien die verfahren und die wege
die preiswert und dann auch überall in
der welt nutzbar zeigen können dass man
wirtschaftlichen wohlstand erreichen
kann ohne das klima so zu
beeinträchtigen
wie ist die menscheit seit dem beginn
der industrialisierung gemacht hat das
ist unsere ingenieurs und unsere zukunft
leistungen die wir hier in deutschland
mit großer kraft
wann bringen müssen herr minister
seehofer ja meine damen und herren
dieser beschluss des bundeskabinetts
heute war sehr wichtig denn nach den
vielfältigen hilfszusagen der letzten
tage haben die menschen natürlich darauf
gewartet dass diesen worten auch taten
folgen
das geschieht jetzt bei den finanziellen
hilfen durch diesen beschluss der in
vielen teilen auf baut auf den
erfahrungen die wir in der vergangenheit
bei solchen katastrophen hatten
wenngleich dies eine tragödie ist ich in
dieser form noch nie erlebt habe obwohl
ich meinen früheren funktionen etliche
hochwasser und schnee katastrophen
erlebt habe ich will jetzt auch wieder
drei punkte anführen und nichts
wiederholen was olaf scholz nicht schon
gesagt hat die soforthilfen sind ja vor
allem eine unterstützung für die
menschen die ihr ganzes hab und gut
verloren haben und deshalb ist es gut
dass man diesen menschen jetzt in den
nächsten tagen hilft dass dies
unbürokratisch erfolgt das scheint mir
ganz wichtig dass da jetzt nicht große
einkommens oder vermögens überprüfungen
stattfinden sondern die hilfe schnell
stattfindet das zweite es war nicht
immer so aber jetzt ist es so dass die
kräfte die vom bund zur verfügung
gestellt werden das sind 8.000
helferinnen und helfer von thw der
bundespolizei
und der bundeswehr das für diesen
einsatz den kommunen keine rechnungen
mehr gestellt werden
das war früher anders das ist für die
kommunen eine deutliche hilfe und das
haben sie auch seit vielen jahren immer
wieder gefordert und der dritte punkt
ist der staatssekretärsausschuss es war
der wunsch der bundesländer dass sie
sich nicht an viele bundes ressorts
wenden müssen wenn es um das
wiederaufbauprogramm geht sondern dass
sie einen ansprechpartner haben den
haben wir heute beschlossen mit einem
staatssekretärsausschuss und die
federführung liegt beim bmf und beim bmi
und wir werden dann im innenverhältnis
der regierung jemand die notwendigen
abstimmungen durchführen
zum beispiel mit dem verkehrsministerium
wenn es um die öffentliche infrastruktur
geht also auch hier eine schlanke lösung
für die abwicklung dieser beschlüsse und
insgesamt jetzt doch ich sage es nochmal
das einlösen der hilfszusagen die von
verschiedenen vertretern vor ort
berechtigterweise der bevölkerung
gegeben worden sind und ich habe bei
meinem eigenen besuchen erlebt dass die
menschen jetzt immer stärker danach
gefragt haben wann kommen jetzt die
hilfen können wir uns darauf verlassen
und deshalb war das heute ein wichtiges
kabinett danke dafür dann kommen wir zu
ihren fragen dazu nochmal die erinnerung
an die regeln die wir seit längerem
haben bitte eine frage pro person
gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage wenn sie
eine weitere frage haben versuche ich
sie gern wieder auf die liste zu nehmen
und ich würde darum bitten dass wir
erstmal bei diesem thema auch bleiben
kabinettsbeschluss finanzielle flut
hilfen dazu noch der hinweis der
bundesinnenminister wird auch noch in
einer zweiten pressekonferenz heute sein
da geht es um die nationale
gesundheitsbehörde und das hat wenn ich
es richtig verstanden habe auch mit dem
thema krisen und katastrophenschutz zu
tun
zu diesem bereich wäre da also auch noch
mal die gelegenheit für fragen
aber dann legen wir erstmal im saal los
und herr rinke hat die erste frage ja
eine frage an herrn scholz
sie haben ja eben auch die 200 millionen
hingewiesen wenn man jetzt die länder zu
sagen die schon gemacht wurden sieht
dann komme ich schon auf 300 millionen
also nrw 200 millionen waren 50
millionen rheinland pfalz ähnlicher
umfang wäre es dann nicht schlauer
gewesen dass der bund gleich mit nach
höheren summe anfängt weil es um 50 50
verhältnis doch eigentlich absehbar ist
dass der bund etwas mehr geld auf den
tisch legen muss für sofort helfen die
aus sorge die ich hier gemacht habe und
die das kabinett heute beschlossen ist
wir werden jedes mal die hälfte dazu
finanzieren das wird also in jedem
umfang sein ob das jetzt am ende eine
summe ist die unterhalb oder weit
oberhalb von 400 mio
das geld steht zur verfügung wir werden
den haushaltsausschuss informieren über
die jetzige außerordentliche notlage bei
der diese hilfe notwendig ist und dann
kann das geld auch bewilligt werden und
sofort zur verfügung stehen und noch mal
ist es ein sehr unbürokratisches
verfahren darauf haben wir gedrungen
dass also nicht dazu führt dass jetzt
der bund die einzelanträge prüft und die
verfahren die die länder festlegen
werden von uns mit finanziert damit geht
es schnell und unbürokratisch dann nehme
ich mal eine frage online gestellt von
gernot heller korrespondentenbüro
herholz er fragt auch den finanzminister
wir werden die hilfen finanziert
insbesondere die milliarden für den
wiederaufbau über einen
nachtragshaushalt kurzfristig oder einen
in anführungsstrichen flut juli
längerfristig wir werden das jetzt mit
den bewilligten haushaltsmitteln
finanzieren die uns zur verfügung
stellen das ist eine außerordentliche
lage die uns auch berechtigt dann solche
mittel zu nutzen und die haushalts
ermächtigung sind ja da für dieses
haushaltsjahr für das nächste gibt es
ein haushaltsgesetz entwürfen aus dem
das jeweils geht also wir können das
machen wir haben dazu die voraussetzung
und es kann sofort losgehen dann hat
hier im saal die nächste frage herr
grimm in der mitte mitte-links
wahrscheinlich hätte eine frage
ob sie ein bisschen beteiligen könnten
wie viel bekommt denn jetzt eine familie
sofort und wird das denen überwiesen
wird das vielleicht sogar bar ausgezahlt
vielleicht könnten sie da ist farbe
geben das geld dann letztlich zu den
leuten kommt ich möchte mich ein
bisschen zurückhaltend in der frage weil
das ja eine regelung ist die die länder
konkret zu treffen haben sie haben aber
von den ländern ja schon gehört dass die
so vorgehen wollen die bundesminister
seehofer das eben auch vorgeschlagen hat
keine einkommensprüfung sondern das wie
personenbezogen beträge überweisen
die dann dem im flutgebiet betroffenen
zur verfügung stehen und ich glaube die
sollten diese auch sagen wir sind glaube
ich schon in der diskussion aber das
wäre nicht angemessen weil es deren
leistung ist die wir mit finanzieren
aber genau so ist der weg da gibt es
dann ganz konkrete beträge überwiesen
werden die nächste frage jeden saal haas
rechts von uns gesehen können sie ein
bisschen näher ans mikro gehen
hergestellt mit viel die einzelnen
länder bekommen von ihnen oder ist das
jetzt wirklich so dass jedes land erst
mal für sich bestimmen kann dass ich
einen bestimmten betrag an soforthilfen
ausgibt und sie geben dann als bund die
hälfte dazu wir haben sind mit denen im
gespräch und deshalb wird es dabei so
laufen dass das nach dem was gebraucht
wird geht wir haben also nicht vor zu
sagen das ist jetzt ein betrag von 200
millionen
und jeder kriegt davon soundsoviel
sondern wenn es eben mehr es wird es
auch mehr sein und deshalb muss das
nicht der maßstab sein
wir haben ja noch gar keine komplette
schadensbilanz sind unglaublich viele
haushalte sind unglaublich viele
familien sind unglaublich viele menschen
betroffen und wer jetzt dass mathematik
übersetzen wollte der hat sich glaube
ich noch gar keinen überblick
verschaffen über das dramatische ausmaß
dieser katastrophe deshalb darf es da
keine limitierung geben wir haben
einschätzung und die tatsache dass er ja
ein
katastrophe schon mal hatten bei der
wehr solche soforthilfen mobilisiert
haben hat uns jetzt zur veranschlagung
veranlasst und wenn es erforderlich es
mehr einzusetzen werden wir das tun
also ich glaube der satz von olaf scholz
schon vor einigen tagen gegeben um geld
wird die hilfe nicht scheitern
den kann man heute noch mit kräftigen
und es ist ja auch vorgesehen bin jetzt
muss ja kursorisch mal der schaden
ermittelt werden
und das soll bis ende juli geschehen und
nicht mit großen gutachten das würde
monate dauern und dann wird es eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben
müssen denn auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man da alle gutwilligen
bundesländer mit ins boot nimmt ist ja
gegeben jedenfalls noch vielen
äußerungen aber wir werden sehen ob die
dann auch anfang august so stehen und da
kann man dann das weitere verfahren
besprechen wie das mit der mit dem
wiederaufbau im privaten bereich usw
vorangeht den öffentlichen bereich so
weit der bund betroffen ist mit straßen
autobahnen und schienen macht ihr der
bund selbst eine frage online gestellt
von frank specht vom handelsblatt die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hätte 2017
beschlossen das motiv für nur noch in
härtefällen gezahlt werden soll
beispielsweise wenn versicherungsschutz
vom versicherer abgelehnt wurde oder
unzumutbar teuer gewesen wäre wie will
man bei der aktuellen nothilfe damit
umgehen
da sind ja immer wieder die betroffenen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten gehört eine auskunft
zu geben aber ich habe alle so
verstanden dass sie jetzt nicht
irgendwie prinzipien zum grundsatz ihrer
entscheidung machen sondern helfen
wollen und deshalb wird es für jeden
jetzt erstmal die soforthilfe geben und
dann werden wir bei dem wiederaufbau von
gebäuden von geschäften von alldem das
stattfindet auch die entsprechenden
mittel zur verfügung stellen
und ich sage nochmal meine haltung dazu
die aber nach meinem eindruck auch die
der ministerpräsident
das ministerpräsidenten und all der
anderen ist es wird keine
individualisierung von risiken geben
dass es keine sache die den einzelnen
bürgerinnen und bürgern zuzuschreiben
ist es muss geholfen werden
die nächste frage im saal qualvollen
ermittelten scholz direkt dazu warum das
ganz klar jetzt verstehen in einer
familie ihr haus verloren hat bekommt
ein neues auf staatskosten die hilfen
die wir gegeben haben waren auch letztes
mal so dass sie den wieder bau des
hauses ermöglicht haben und wir haben
dazu ganz hohe beträge überwiesen damit
diese finanzierung möglich sind das wird
auch jetzt erforderlich sein wenn jemand
von einem solchen ereignis betroffen ist
dann kann er nichts dafür ich finde das
muss man doch ausdrücklich sagen die
bürgerinnen und bürger sind doch nicht
schuld an dem unglück dass ihm passiert
ist sondern das müssen wir der
menschheit insgesamt hinblick auf den
klimawandel zu rechnen da müssen wir
eine gemeinschaftliche verantwortung
übernehmen wir können die nicht alleine
lassen ja es ist so dass dazu die mittel
bereitgestellt werden selbstverständlich
das letzte mal waren elf bundesländer
betroffen mit einem volumen in diesem
sektor auf bauhöfen von sechs milliarden
dafür zahlen die leute ja steuern dass
ihnen auch in außergewöhnlichen
situationen geholfen wird
nicht alles ist versicherbar das wissen
wir auf diesem feld im saal geht es
weiter mit der nächsten frage bei herrn
decker setzt genau deutschland scholz
sie haben schon
frühjahr jahres im zusammenhang mit
corona von der hat es bazooka gesprochen
die sie rausholen wollten oder nutzen
wollten
jetzt haben wir eine neue neue schäden
eine neue katastrophe neuen finanzbedarf
und die haben selber gerade gesagt es
ist damit zu rechnen dass wir solche
katastrophen wie in der folgewoche noch
öfter erleben
vor diesem hintergrund die frage sehen
sie die gefahr dass der staat da früher
oder später an seine leistungsgrenzen
stoßen wir haben in den letzten jahren
sehr gut gewirtschaftet die wissen dass
die korona pandemie ausgebrochen ist mit
2009 10 eine situation hatten wir
sämtliche stabilitätskriterien europas
hierzulande erfüllt haben und das ist
natürlich die grundlage dafür dass wir
jetzt die kraft haben gegen die korona
pandemien ihre wirtschaftlichen sozialen
folgen anzugehen was unglaubliche summen
verschlungen hat jetzt geht es noch mal
um eine große summe aber dass es jetzt
keine so dramatische veränderung dessen
was wir in unserer finanzplanung
vorgesehen werden dass also bewältigen
können allerdings ist klar dass das
immerhin voraussetzt dass wir eine
leistungsfähige wirtschaft haben dass
wir dafür sorgen dass wir bei dem
industriellen umbau um den es geht wenn
die co2 neutral wirtschaften wollen
alles dafür tun dass wir wohlstand und
arbeitsplätze dabei sogar ausbauen und
nicht gefährden was geht die
voraussetzung dazu ist vor wenigen tagen
ja jetzt allgemeines wissen geworden
nämlich dass wir einen erheblichen
ausbau der energieerzeugung mit
erneuerbaren strom brauchen und dann
wird es uns auch gelingen solcher
herausforderungen zu bewältigen
eben sagen hat die nächste frage frau
gammelin sie habe ich auf der liste
denn die können sie bitte das mikro vor
sich nehmen das vertragen die besser so
da müsste ich muss das richtige
anschalten moment jetzt ja ich hätte
hier eine frage die stimmung im kabinett
zwar sehr kollegialer und aber sehr
ernsthaft denn wir hatten ausschließlich
auch sehr ernste probleme die pandemie
die ortskräfte aus afghanistan des
migrations geschehen diese
hilfsprogramme die einreise verordnung
die wir auch beschlossen haben und
verlängert haben
und der grund für die leichte verspätung
von olaf scholz und mir liegt nicht in
einem problem das wir im kabinett hatten
außer den sachlichen themen und
problemen sondern einfach in der fülle
der dinge die wir wirklich heute sehr
tief beraten haben es wird noch an der
anpassung der regelung zum
härtefallfonds gearbeitet
es gibt ja ein härtefallfonds im rahmen
der wirtschafts helfen und der ist
glaube ich dann auch eine wiederum von
den ländern auszugestalten eine
praktische regelung im umgang dieser
frage
erstattungen geben wir werden den harten
treffern nutzbar machen ist die
diskussion die wir gegenwärtig führen
und das ist wahrscheinlich auch das
pragmatisch derweil es nicht darum geht
dass wir jetzt als bundesregierung
konkrete einzelregelungen entwickeln
sondern wir möchten ganz konkret die
erfahrung und praxis vor ort wirken
lassen das heißt die länder sollen
entscheiden wie es geht das wollen wir
bei allen sachen machen dass es vor ort
die gemeinden die landkreise die länder
müssen so viel freiheit wie möglich
haben und wir wollen sie dabei nicht
beeinträchtigt
die nächste frage hat hier im saal von
uns aus gesehen auf der linken seite der
kollegen ja ja ich wollte ja mal
nachfragen ob ich das richtig verstanden
aber die 6 milliarden in eine zielgröße
für das treffen mit den
ministerpräsidenten also sie würden
jetzt schon 3 milliarden zu sagen oder
dass man einen rückblick auf das letzte
mal nach dem die sechs milliarden ich
genannt habe möchte ich dem ausdrücklich
widersprechen
ich habe mir gesagt das war das letzte
mal glaube ich 2013 noch in anderer
funktion
dass ausgabe von woman dass wir für
damals elf betroffene bundesländer
aufgewendet haben
aber ich bitte jetzt dann nicht den
rückschluss zu ziehen das sei die
orientierungsgröße für diesmal ich frage
nur deshalb nach weils ja diesmal wäre
das aufkommen wahrscheinlich sogar noch
höher
das kann sein und ich glaube wenn man
vor ort waren sich die zerstörung
angeguckt hat was wir beide gemacht
haben dann hat man das gefühl dass das
hier eine richtig große herausforderung
ist das waren jetzt erst mal elf
bundesländer das heißt viel mehr länder
berührt von den damaligen zerstörung
aber das was hier stattgefunden hat das
ist sehr sehr groß ich will noch mal
die zahl der toten die bisher schon
feststehen die ist dort dramatisch und
ich weiß nicht ich jedenfalls bin
unverändert total berührt von diesem
dramatischen schicksals sagte der
stattgefunden hat und der auch für mich
immer nur bedeuten kann dass wir sagen
wir stehen hier als land zusammen das
muss doch das sein was wir jetzt machen
die nächste frage der kollege davor gehe
auch lenkung südwestrundfunk wir haben
ja trotzdem das problem dass ein
hausbesitzer seine policen über jahre
bezahlt hat und jetzt das gleich weg wir
das nicht gemacht hat wir haben in baden
württemberg eine versicherungspflicht
gehabt elementarschadenversicherung da
haben sie das gleiche nur bis 93 haben
die 4 90 prozent aller hausbesitzer
haben diese elementarschadenversicherung
ist das nicht jetzt spätestens der
zeitpunkt wo man sagen muss dass muss
verpflichtend für alle kommen diese
debatte wird stattfinden und sie wird
auch unter den ländern diskutiert werden
wie sie ja aus den bericht der stadt und
rückmeldungen vieler beteiligter gehört
haben gibt es viele folge fragen zu
beantworten weil mit dem ersten satz und
viele weitere fragestellungen verbunden
die alle einer vertieften erörterung
bedürfen
und das ist die rückmeldung die ich habe
daran machen sich jetzt alle das muss ja
16.00 richtig gefunden haben wir heute
auch beschlossen dass darüber gesprochen
werden muss über eine absicherung system
der zukunft
die art und weise offen gelassen aber es
muss jetzt weil wir ja in immer kürzeren
abständen immer heftigere
naturereignisse bekommen unsere
gemeinsame einschätzung muss man jetzt
auch eine breite debatte über ab
sicherungssysteme führen
es ist der start ist die versicherung
gemeinsam mit privatleuten und wie
gestaltet man das gerächt haben dass in
bayern 2013 ebenso gemacht die
versicherungsleistungen dann
abgezogen wurden von der fördersumme das
ist wurde nicht jemand dann doppelt
bedient so zu sagen aber das muss man
alles mit den ländern besprechen im
detail aber dass wir darüber reden
müssen vor dem hintergrund den sie
selbst angeführt haben ist heute
beschlossen worden
dann machen wir im saal weiter bei frau
wefers in der mitte die sich für das
mikro auf einer seite entscheiden muss
das noch eine praktische frage zu den zu
den hilfen wie werden die ausgezahlt
brauchen sie da wieder die
investitionsbanken in den ländern werden
da die sparkassen und die volksbanken
die ja vor ort der stadt einbezogen
wohin muss man sich wenden
das werden die beiden landesregierungen
bekanntgeben
jedes land für sich mit einem eigenen
verfahren aber das was schnell und zügig
funktioniert und das haben wir beide
schon berichtet aus der diskussion ist
jetzt über konkrete beträge geredet die
ausgezahlt werden sollen pro familie pro
person
es wird über kumulierte beträge geredet
dass das daraus machen kann
und bei allem immer ohne
einkommensprüfung dass das möglichst
schnell fließt weil wenn man jetzt noch
solche verfahren der zwischenschichten
wird das zu lange dauern
und viele von denen die jetzt das prüfen
müssten werden ja auch gebraucht zu
helfen das für den wiederaufbau in
kriegen dass die schäden beseitigt
werden das noch jetzt gerettet wird
sein verfahren aussetzen aber es musste
einen weg geben das muss ein weg geben
und es wird keine damit es schnell geht
wird das geben wir das geld und die
länder und die länder zahlen das aus und
sie werden sich dazu den in ihrem land
jeweils schnellsten weg aus den zuletzt
war sie über die landräte und
bürgermeister vor ort immer in
abstimmung mit der landesregierung aber
ob das jetzt auch so läuft ist noch
offen
das können nur die länder entscheiden
die nächste frage am gleichen micro
großen felder der rosenfelder von bild
wir haben es beide angesprochen wir
müssen damit rechnen dass ich solche
ereignisse in zukunft häufen werden
viele länder machen schon seit broadcast
warnen die die bürger in
katastrophengebieten deutschlands prüft
jetzt erst mal wann werden die bürger in
deutschland auch gewarnt in solchen
situationen in denen es um leben und tod
geht das thema wollten wir eigentlich
hintenanstellen thema katastrophenschutz
vielleicht können sie es kurz gerät
wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell zu
beantworten kann ist verbindet damit die
hoffnung dass sie in der anschließenden
pressekonferenz noch mal dabei sind
ich bin ich noch kurz sagen wir
präsident des bundesamtes für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
war zu diesem thema zum ersten mal im
januar dieses jahres im digital
ausschuss des bundestages
ich habe der neue präsident der von mir
im november des letzten jahres bestellt
wurde
ich habe eben märz gemeinsam mit ihm
hier vor der bundespressekonferenz
vorgestellt
das neue konzept des bbk zur
unterstützung der länder nicht um den
ländern kompetenzen weg zu nehmen was
ich nach wie vor vertreten übrigens in
abstimmung mit allen 16 bundesländern
und in diesem konzept ist von ein großer
punkt warnung der bevölkerung und der
beginnt mit dem satz dass man die
analogen und digitalen waren medien
miteinander verknüpfen muss und dann in
der ausführung dieser überschrift
ist davon die rede dass wir die in den
letzten jahren abgebauten sirenen wieder
aufbauen wollen das ist die erkenntnis
nach dem baden tag sind ja in großen
städten weite stadtteile
keine serie mehr bestückt und diese rede
ist noch immer die auch die akustisch
wahrnehmbar erste form der warnung da
muss man dann überlegen ob man aber
unterschiedliche warnsignale für den
einsatz der feuerwehr und für solche
umweltkatastrophen hat das hatte man
früher
und dann steht auch der satz die nutzung
von zellen braut casting wird aktuell
geprüft
das war im märz dieses jahres und die
prüfung ist im mai eingeleitet worden
und ich kann ihnen sagen dass nach dem
gespräch das ich heute früh noch mit dem
präsidenten des bundesamtes hatte er
damit rechnet dass wir noch vor der
bundestagswahl das ergebnis dieser
prüfung bekommen nach seiner
einschätzung wird ist ein positives sein
aber ich möchte deutlich darauf
hinweisen dass wir das zusammenwirken
aller möglichkeiten der warnung bekommen
also die akustische warnung die digitale
warnung auf dem smartphone
das alles muss zusammen spielen die
bevölkerung das reicht ja nicht aus nur
akustisch zu warnen und die bevölkerung
war es nicht was sie tun soll sondern
sie muss ja auch erfahren wie sie sich
jetzt verhalten sollte in welchen
situationen und deshalb ist der satz mit
der verknüpfung von analogen und
digitalen waren medien ein unheimlich
wichtiger es gibt da nicht die eine
lösung die alles ist das verstehe ich
aber wenn sie sagen im september ist das
geprüft mit man wirklich positiven
ergebnis wann wird es dann solche wagen
erst in deutschland auch geben
wenn ich noch da bin unverzüglich man
weiß ja nie im zusammenhang mit wahlen
soll es ist ja das ist unsere pflicht
auch das förderprogramm mit 88 millionen
mit den serien läuft ja wir sind ja mit
den ländern in abstimmung werden gestern
abend eine sonder innenministerkonferenz
haben die dinge besprochen und stehen
auf dem was wir ihnen schon seit monaten
ankündigen wir haben ja das bwk völlig
neu strukturiert das war bisher
ausschließlich für den spannungs und
verteidigungsfall zuständig sie dürften
nur maßnahmen treffen die sie auch im
verteidigungsfall gebraucht hätten
und immer wenn sie darüber hinaus gehen
wollten hatten sie schwierigkeiten mit
dem rechnungshof zu recht weil das
gesetz eben diese begrenzung vorsieht
dies war bei der gründung des bbk sicher
richtig aber wir haben in der pandemie
gelernt dass es schwer erklärbar ist
warum eine bundesbehörde ressourcen hat
in der lagebeurteilung in der
bevorratung von gesundheits material die
sie aber dann in friedens fallen nicht
einsetzen da das war der ausgangspunkt
dass wir gesagt haben wir wollen das
erweitern die befugnis des bbk und
möglicherweise brauchen wir dann auch im
herbst dazu zu der generellen
erweiterung auch eine kleine
gesetzesänderung noch mal ne frau
rosenfelder wir hatten eigentlich
committed dass wir hier vorher die
anderen fragen machen ich habe noch
mindestens zehn fragen zum eigentlichen
thema der pk deswegen noch mal der
hinweis auf die anschließende
veranstaltung und würde jetzt gerne
wieder mit dem anderen thema weiter
machen hier im saal der kollege dann
eben rechts karsten seibel von der welt
ich möchte auch noch die
versicherungsfrage zurückkommen warum
herrscht soll jetzt überhaupt noch
jemand trainieren für seine
elementarschaden versicherung bezahlen
wenn der staat doch in solchen fällen
dann uneingeschränkt dafür ob ich nehme
an der stelle die frage von uwe lück vom
ard hörfunk dazu der im prinzip in die
ähnliche richtung fragt müssen nicht
besitzer verpflichtet werden ihre
immobilien gegen elementarschäden zu
versichern
das ist die frage an die zukunft dazu
haben ich und horst seehofer auch noch
der debatte im kabinett was gesagt wir
wollen nicht mit den ländern darüber
verständigen wie das sein soll wenn das
für die zukunft eine richtige
vorgehensweise ist dann muss das
festgelegt werden und hat dann für die
zukunft konsequenzen
und es ist nur eine frage die nicht mit
dem einsatz zu ende ist und da gibt es
dann die frage gibt es unterschiedliche
tarife und so weiter und so fort die
alle dann noch mit beantwortet werden
müssen und das wird noch sehr mühselig
für das was jetzt ist müssen wir jetzt
helfen
also ich plädiere dafür nicht zynisch zu
sein und nicht herzlos zu sein denn es
geht hier um eine große katastrophe und
da muss geholfen werden das muss die
erste priorität haben und nicht
irgendwelche prinzipien der nachfrage
aber jetzt keinerlei bedingungen oder
keine unterscheidung zwischen jenen die
sich um eine versicherung bemüht haben
bekommen haben oder leisten konnten und
irgendwie
es wird von den ländern eine konkrete
regelung getroffen werden das ist muss
auch letztes mal wie herr seehofer aus
seiner damaligen erfahrung als
ministerpräsident berichtet hatten hatte
bereits gegenstand von regelung gewesen
dann wird also die versicherungsleistung
schon berücksichtigen können und auch
insgesamt in dem was dort gemacht wird
unterstützung organisieren die fragen
wie viel konkret gezahlt wird muss ja
noch genau festgelegt werden und das
alles findet in einer sehr pragmatischen
schnellen entscheidung zusammen mit dem
statt deshalb haben wir diesen ausschuss
eingerichtet über dem gebäude berichtet
haben damit das jetzt nicht lange
diskussionen und verhandlungen gibt
sondern wir die konzepte der länder da
einmal begutachten und sagen okay die
sollten auch zusammenpassen also wenn
ich einen rat geben dafür sollte kann
der unterschiedlichen
soforthilfemaßnahmen norden des vereins
und in rheinland pfalz geben und es
sollte auch bei der frage der
aufbauhilfe keine strukturell
unterschiedlichen regelungen geben und
die sollten gemeinsam sagen meine unsere
vorstellung ist das sollte ganz schnell
dort geklärt werden die länder legen das
vor wir werden uns bei all dem
orientieren an dem was wir schon mal
erfahren haben bei der letzten flut
hilfe da hat es für all diese probleme
sehr pragmatische sehr gute lösung
gegeben ein punkt wird man sagen kann
man vielleicht ein bisschen besser
machen aber so grundlegend anders wird
das nicht sein
und darauf können sich die bürgerinnen
und bürger auch verlassen das ist das
was sie jetzt wissen müssen dass sie
nicht verzweifelt sitzen ob alles wieder
gut werden wird doch das was wir
materiell entschieden gut machen können
das wollen wir gut machen das was an
menschlicher katastrophe entstanden ist
das werden wir nicht rückgängig machen
können aber den anderen teil dazu
sollten wir uns dann schon verpflichten
und manche können sich nicht versichern
auch wenn sie wollen
wenn sie in passau direkt an der donau
wohnen werden sie nehmen und finden der
das versichert ist es her komplexer
sachverhalt und deshalb ist es richtig
die noch mal intensiv mit den ländern zu
besprechen
er schaut sie haben von den materiellen
zerstörungen gesprochen vielleicht nicht
zerstört aber doch zumindest angegriffen
ist doch aber auch das vertrauen in die
krisenreaktion fähigkeit staatlicher
institutionen können sie bürgern die vor
den trümmern ihrer existenz in
mehrfacher hinsicht jetzt stehen
versichern dass niemand von denen
tatsächlich seine existenz sei es über
das haus sei es über den beruf sei es
über ein unternehmen tatsächlich
verlieren wird können sie das verhindern
durch den einsatz der staatlichen mittel
die sie hier vorgestellt haben um diese
sicherheit geht es darum machen wir das
die versicherung gar nicht wie ich habe
mit ganz vielen ganz konkret gesprochen
und die machen sich ganz große sorgen da
ist ein lebenswerk kaputt gegangen dass
in 30 jahren aufgebaut worden ist da
hatten die ganze familie gehabt dass
irgendwelche dinge funktionieren
und jetzt ist alles auf einmal kaputt da
kann man doch nur sagen da werden wir
für sorgen dass es wieder weitergeht
und dazu werden die mittel auch
eingesetzt und ich meine das sind ja
große summen über die wir hier reden die
sind deshalb so groß weil wir genau das
gewährleisten wurden sie versichern den
betroffenen bürgern dass niemand von
ihnen aufgrund der flutkatastrophe seine
existenz dauerhaft verlieren wird wir
werden genau das tun wir werden leben
wieder aufbauen deren geschäft wieder
aufbauen wir werden fabriken wieder
aufbauen wir werden gebäude wieder
errichten wir werden dafür sorgen dass
die unternehmen wieder loslegen können
dazu dienen soforthilfe und aufbauhilfe
und dazu haben wir auch die erfahrungen
dass das funktionieren kann dann ein
paar weiten herein weiter vorn die
kollegen hinter großen pferde von der
dpa tmn von dem aufbau system für die
zukunft gesprochen denken sie da auch
war so eine art dauerhaften
naturkatastrophen fonds im haushalt nach
also sonate werben
wir wollen genau darüber wenn wir mit
den ländern diskutieren uns beraten und
verständigen
es geht um ein absicherungs system da
steht die eine frage die jetzt mehrfach
angesprochen worden ist eine rolle was
kann man möglicherweise
im bereich von versicherung machen aber
das wird ja niemals reichen und auch nie
wirklich auf solche fälle in die
probleme damit lösen und das nochmal
ganz klar gesagt ich bin eindeutig dafür
dass wir in einer situation in der der
klimawandel jetzt jeden sichtbar auch zu
großen schäden führt die über das
hinausgehen was wir immer schon am
großen naturzerstörung auch erleben
müssen und wo man immer wieder erneut
erlebt welche große kraft und in der
natur aufstieg mitsprechen
zerstörerischen konsequenzen auch an
vielen stellen
aber wo das doch ganz offensichtlich
eine folge des menschengemachten
klimawandels ist müssen wir vorsorge
treffen indem wir uns auf solche
ereignisse einstellen und investitionen
leisten in infrastrukturen die damit
umgehen können müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass den leuten geholfen wird und müssen
wir natürlich den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufhalten was das helfen
betrifft kann ich mir vorstellen dass
ein solches ab sicherungssystem bedeutet
dass sich die länder und der bund auf
einen solchen fonds verständigen den sie
praktisch etablieren und wo sie dafür
sorgen dass der immer in der lage ist zu
handeln das ist aber zu gesprächen mit
all den anderen folgen aber ich glaube
das ist jetzt auch der richtige
zeitpunkt wo wir mit der erfahrung der
letzten großen flutkatastrophe mit dem
wissen um das was wir jetzt tun
gewissermaßen und auf diese frage
vorbereiten
das ist eine angelegenheit der
solidarität und keine angelegenheit bei
dem jemand alleine mit seinem schicksal
bleibt
dazu nehme ich mir noch die frage dazu
von birgit marschall rheinische post sie
fragt mit hinweis auf die klimaschutz
notwendigkeiten welche klimapolitische
konsequenz muss ganz konkret aus der
katastrophe gezogen werden wie viel mehr
geld soll künftig pro jahr in
klimaschutz gehen meine unsere
einschätzung ist dass das jetzt eine
große veränderung mit sich bringen wird
wir haben ja schon
festgelegt dass wir 2045 und sehr kurzer
zeit von jetzt an co2 neutral
wirtschaften wollen
das wären 40 milliarden sowie ein
privatwirtschaftlicher aber auch
öffentlicher investitionen seien die
dazu notwendig sind damit wir
industrieland sind weltweit
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sind gute gut
bezahlte arbeitsplätze haben und dass
mit dem co2 neutralen wirtschaften
hinkriegen und eine der voraussetzungen
wie gesagt ist der dramatische ausbau
der erzeugungskapazitäten für
erneuerbare hergestellten strom
denn der wird führt die frage der co2
neutralen industrie von größter
bedeutung sein und alleine dass das meer
also was das für eine veränderung
bedeutet kann man ja sehen
vor kurzem hat die chemieindustrie
mitgeteilt sie braucht 2040 ungefähr
2045 2050 so viel strom wie heute
deutschland insgesamt erzeugt für ihre
prozesse sie haben die vorausberechnung
gehört die vor wenigen tagen hier glaube
ich vorgestellt wurden in bezug auf den
zusätzlichen strombedarf bis 2030
ich habe darüber schon seit sehr langer
zeit immer mal wieder gesprochen weil
ich fest davon überzeugt dass wir uns
auf die tatsache dass da ein großer
industrieller modernisierungsprozess
stattfinden muss einstellen müssen und
das nicht für eine kleine aufgabe halten
dürfen aber genau das müssen wir jetzt
alles machen
ich hoffe also ich bin sehr überzeugt
dass es sinn macht all die vorgesehenen
maßnahmen noch mal daraufhin abzuklopfen
ob man das tempo noch erhöhen kann
konzentriere mich jetzt auf meinen
zuständigkeitsbereich den gebäudebereich
hier ganz erheblich zum klimaschutz
beitragen kann
zwei drittel des gebäudebestandes in
deutschland sind altbauten
man kann jetzt den weg begehen altbauten
zu sanieren das macht bei jüngeren
altbauten vielleicht sind aber wenn
schon jahrzehnte auf dem gebäude liegen
macht es aus unserer sicht mehr sinn ein
neues gebäude hin zu stellen
deshalb bin ich dankbar dass wir die
ergänzung des klimaschutzgesetzes vor
wenigen wochen auch wieder eine
milliarde zur verfügung gestellt haben
das heißt genau der finanzminister um
zum beispiel sozialwohnungen die ja
meistens älteren datums sind neu zu
bauen das hat eine ganz andere energie
effizienz welt von den fenstern von der
heizung von der dämmung und so müsste
man ganz nüchtern jedem bereich
durchgehend wo kann man das tempo im
sinne von mehr klimaschutz noch erhöhen
und ich glaube es ist in vielen
bereichen noch möglich auch wenn man oft
glaubt es ist schon alles ausgequetscht
keine frage die vielleicht auch noch zu
diesem komplex passt von daniel haas vom
handelsblatt er fragt sie beide wie
bewerten sie den gefundenen kompromiss
mit den weitreichenden ausnahmen für
industrie und stromnetzen im
hochwasserschutz plan
und wie soll der plan konkret finanziert
werden mehr ausgleichsflächen zum schutz
vor hochwasser zu schaffen
ja das ist eine frage die in meinem haus
läuft nämlich zum ersten mal so was wie
einen raumordnungsplan das ist
gegenstand der heimat abteilung für auch
für hochwasserschutz und sie können sich
vorstellen dass deren in der entstehung
heftig diskutiert wurde nicht zu sagen
umstritten ist und
da wird jetzt behauptet da gab es so
viele ausnahmen für bestimmte interessen
und so was hört ja immer dazu in einem
ministerium dass man sich die dinge noch
mal anschaut
aber es wäre das erste mal dass auf
bundesebene solche raumordnung wenn im
hinblick auf den hochwasserschutz
durchgeführt worden das ist ein prozess
der schon mehrere jahre läuft
der jetzt schluss reich ist und jetzt
diese diskussion auslöst sind die
ausnahmen die man da vorgesehen hat
berechtigt oder nicht
wir schauen uns das noch mal an dann hat
der kollege in der mitte jahr aufweist
ich wollte noch einmal präzise
nachfragen zu den versicherungen
das ist schon so angedacht jetzt dass
die versicherungszahlungen voll
angerechnet werden sich dadurch eine
höchstleistung sodass es also unterm
strich egal ist ob man für sich hat war
oder nicht und daran anschließend das
wird ja auch relativ viel gespendet im
moment für die flutopfer
gibt es denn schon überlegungen wofür
die spendengelder verwendet werden
sollen wenn der private wenn der staat
im prinzip schon für sämtliche schäden
zu 100 prozent auf kommt die
hilfsorganisation die jetzt zu spenden
leistungen aufrufen
selbst bestimmen wofür sie diese mittel
einsetzen
das ist das dass das prinzip dort ist
und noch mal wir werden ja eine konkrete
entscheidung treffen oder vielmehr die
länder werden an dem treffen über die
höhe der konkreten hilfsleistungen für
den wiederaufbau von gebäuden oder von
geschäften zum beispiel
und natürlich werden die
versicherungssumme dabei eine rolle
spielen das hat er war alles schon mal
praktisch stattgefunden also da war ein
interesse aber auch dass niemand mehr
als 100 prozent krieg nicht glauben das
ist ein öffentliches interesse dass
nicht nur hier im raum sondern auch
sonst alle teilen
und ansonsten gibt es da vernünftige
wege die die pragmatisch diese
herausforderungen lösen die mit ihrer
hagel verbunden sind hat es auch letztes
mal gegeben und die wird es jetzt auch
wieder ganz konkret bei den einzel
festlegung der länder geben nochmal
bitte kein zynismus keine
prinzipienreiterei nicht die leute
alleine lassen weil man einen grundsatz
hat könnte ja so was wie eine
interessensgruppe vorsehen dass jemand
der sich versichert hat auch daraus
einen vorteil hat wenn er jahre lang
bezahlt hat aber wie gesagt das muss
besprochen werden das können wir nicht
von berlin aus
ob trüben ich denke wird man überlegen
wie man berücksichtigt dass sich jemand
versichert was allerdings jetzt eine
eine absicherung dann über 150% ist auch
schwer vorstellbar
ich habe auf der liste jetzt nochmal mit
neuen fragen herrn rinke hahn york war
und herrn grimmen und dann würde ich
auch dass für die für heute bewenden
lassen dass wir hier nochmal lüften
können vor der nächsten veranstaltungen
haring fürbitte ja ganz kurze nachfrage
an den innenminister
sie hatten erwähnt dass der bund die
kosten für den einsatz von 8.000 kräften
den kommunen nicht in rechnung gestellt
nur um so eine große vorstellung zu
bekommen können sie das jetzt zu
beziffern was dafür kosten anfallen
und also ich kann beim besten willen
jetzt nicht beziffern
das waren jedenfalls immer rechnungen
die die kommunen erhalten haben die viel
ärger ausgelöst haben viel unwillen ich
kann mich erinnern an die
schneekatastrophe in bayern wo das thw
sehr stark im einsatz war um die dächer
vom schnee zu befreien
und da kommen dann rechnungen 50.000 und
150.000 und 200.000 und dann müssen sie
verständnis haben für die landräte
oberbürgermeister bürgermeister die
sagen jetzt kommt der bund hilft uns
manchmal lässt er sich noch loben dafür
und dann schickte uns eigentlich
rechnung dass das passt nicht zusammen
und deshalb bin ich über diesen
beschluss des kabinetts
auch wenn er jetzt nicht in die
begehrten geht sehr sehr froh dass wir
festgelegt haben wir stellen keine
rechnungen damit ist eine saubere
rechtsgrundlage gegeben und ich kann
ihnen beim besten willen zur stunde
nicht sagen und es dauert natürlich
solange es notwendig ist fachlich
solange die katastrophenhilfe in
notwendig ist
für diesen zeitraum gilt ist ganz
einfach und kurze frage gab es
eigentlich hilfsangebote aus dem ausland
in welcher form auch immer geld oder
gerät also haben wir haben wir heute im
kabinett auch geredet die kanzlerin hat
darüber berichtet scholz ab berichtet
die staatsministerin im auswärtigen amt
dass sie praktisch flächendeckend war
erstens die solidarität die anteilnahme
aber auch die das angebot der hilfe mir
war gestern erst der israelische
botschafter die an einen sehr schönen
akt der solidarität ja gezeigt indem sie
ihre gebäude beleuchtet haben und damit
ihre solidarität ausgedrückt haben
umgekehrt gab es auch hilfeersuchen
gerade im grenznahen raum belgien
niederlande an uns und trotz des hohen
einsatzes unserer hilfskräfte haben wir
zum beispiel für belgien dann auch noch
hubschrauber zur verfügung gestellt also
wie ich überhaupt sagen möchte wir haben
hier ein ausmaß an solidarität national
und international erlebt einen
zusammenhalt der unbeschreiblich ist
wenn man den direkt vor ort oder am
telefon wenn
der belgische spanische innenministerium
sieht wird und das ist trotz der ganzen
tragen die auch eine schöne erfahrung
diese solidarität unter konkrete
hilfsangebote mit geld oder gerät aus
dem ausland noch immer verbunden mit der
anteilnahme von überall her aus europa
und der ganzen nachbarn italien
tschechien österreich sowieso schweiz
frankreich obwohl sie selbst auch in zu
hoher belastung sind zum teil also das
haben wir heute sehr gut ausgetauscht
und das ist eine schöne erfahrung
herr seehofer zum abschluss erwischte es
ja dann immer mal in der anderen pk
werden sie denn sagen dass die
alarmierung gut gelaufen ist oder ob es
da eigentlich erheblichen
verbesserungsbedarf gibt bei diesen
ereignissen extremwetter also wir hatten
gestern abend eine sonder
innenministerkonferenz insbesondere mit
den ländern die direkt betroffen sind
wir haben in deutschland die
verfassungslage das für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
in friedenszeiten die länder zuständig
sind die ihrerseits einen teil ihrer
zuständigkeit auf die kommunen
übertragen haben aber jederzeit wieder
anstelle der kommunen tätig werden
können und den spannungsvollen
kriegszeiten der bund der bund
unterstützt die länder was wir jetzt in
diesem fall auch wieder mit bundeswehr
thw und bundespolizei gemacht haben
und der deutsche wetterdienst
informiert mit einem sauberen klaren
verfahren die stellen die im
zusammenhang mit einer unwetter
drohenden unwetter katastrophe dann zu
entscheiden haben wir können da im bund
gar nichts entscheiden weil wir die
zuständigkeit nicht haben und das ist
kein abdrängen der der verantwortung
sondern es ist eine beschreibung dessen
was unserem grundgesetz sauber geregelt
ist was ich auch für richtig halten
übrigens haben alle 16
landesinnenminister die sehr
unterschiedlich regiert werden
diese position noch einmal bekräftigt
stellen sie sich vor wir sollen aus
berlin heraus
die entscheidung für weiler treffen das
ist objektiv unmöglich die einsatzkräfte
zu koordinieren und all diesen diese
dinge
der deutsche wetterdienst hat diese
warnungen herausgegeben auch sehr
frühzeitig das unbestreitbar und sie
sind da haben die zuständigen stellen
nahmen 150 fällen erfolgt dann haben die
stellen die für den katastrophenschutz
zuständig sind zu entscheiden und da
haben wir gestern abend so diskutiert
keine kein großer ereignisse so dass
sich die politik zurücklehnen sollte und
sagen sollte es war alles ganz perfekt
sondern dass wir zu gegebener zeit
natürlich diese dinge auswerten müssen
und auch bereit sein müssen
verbesserungen durchzuführen
vor allem auf den feldern wo wir schon
weit vor dieser katastrophe ja uns
entschieden haben dass die bundesbehörde
reformieren wollen nicht weil sie
jetzt anstelle der länder mehr
kompetenzen bekommen soll sondern mehr
unterstützungsmöglichkeiten für die
länder
und da ist ein punkt den körper gerne
ihnen auch zur verfügung stellen über
eine ganze din a4 seite warnung der
bevölkerung
das ist im märz hier in diesem jahr
vorgestellt worden
leider war die beteiligung bei weitem
nicht so hoch wie heute und da ist ganz
klar beschrieben was wir für
erforderlich halten da wussten wir von
dieser katastrophe naturgemäß noch
überhaupt nichts jetzt können wir nicht
im märz hier vor der öffentlichkeit
vorstellen wir brauchen eine verknüpfung
von analogen und digitalen digitalen
medien wir müssen diese regeln wieder
aufbauen in deutschland und wir müssen
allen braut casting
aktuell prüfen ich habe vorher
geschildert was ja auch mit hochdruck
dann geschehen ist und noch vor der
bundestagswahl ergebnisse zeitigen wird
jetzt kann ich das eher die märz hier
der öffentlichkeit verkündet und sagen
heute ist es nicht mehr
real das war völlig unabhängig von der
hochwasserkatastrophe wir können uns ja
auch chemieunfälle biologische unfälle
und solche katastrophen vorstellen auch
wenn man sie heute noch nicht gerne in
den köpfen auf nimmt aber wir müssen
auch das undenkbare denken in der
vorsorge für den schutz unserer
bevölkerung und dazu gehört eine moderne
warnung der bevölkerung und das ist das
konzept das wir seit november letzten
jahres verfolgen mit den neuen
präsidenten nämlich mehr vorsorge
politik und sie werden ja in kürze in
wenigen minuten auch familien sparen
hören dass wir beginnen mit der
gesundheitsvorsorge aus als lehre aus
der pandemie und dann geht es weiter
jetzt natürlich mit hochdruck
hochwasserschutz
dann geht es weiter mit sensiblen
infrastrukturen auch mit einem cyber
angriffen großkraftwerke in der fläche
stillgelegt werden an denen wieder die
krankenhäuser hängen
also wir müssen solche szenarien
durchdenken und dann auch mit vorsorge
versehen aber ich weiß davor setzen sie
banner halbe stunde zu lüften
aber es soll bei den kompetenzen bleiben
die länder
das haben sie auch gestern abend 16 noch
einmal bekräftigt und der bund und der
bund unterstützt in friedenszeiten
massiv die länder und dazu brauchen wir
ein bbk das auch von den ressourcen her
in der lage ist zu unterstützen also die
die meldungen liefen problemlos unter
anführungszeichen auch die technik hat
gestimmt wir werden aber sicher
analysieren gemeinsam mit den ländern
die das dann vor ort stattgefunden hat
wie ist die bevölkerung informiert
worden mit welchem inhalt wusste die
bevölkerung oder konnte es überhaupt
wissen was auf sie zukommt in den
nächsten tagen oder stunden und da waren
wir gestern auch alle einig dass eine
solche analyse stattfinden soll
und übrigens nach jedem großer eigenen
stattgefunden hat auch der
hochwasserschutz wird der rolle spielen
ich weiß wovon ich rede in bayern wie
schwer es ist
ich habe heute im kabinett gesagt wenn
man das nahe zum schadensereignis tut
dann hat man noch das verständnis weil
die erinnerung noch im kopf ist wenn man
sich einige jahre danach befindet dann
ist es furchtbar schwer zum beispiel
flut polder was wir gerade in bayern
leben zu realisieren weil das
verständnis dass man ein rückstau für
das wasser zur verfügung haben muss dann
nicht mehr sofort das sind also schon
komplexe sachverhalte müssen uns in den
ställen
ich kann mir vorstellen dass es dazu
auch noch in der nächsten veranstaltung
fragen gibt um halb eins gibt es geht es
hier weiter dazu der hinweis für den
moment vielen dank an unsere gäste fürs
kommen und ihnen für center
tschüss